[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
seitdem die Bundesregierung nicht mehr
aus einer großen Koalition besteht ist
auch der Parlamentsbetrieb wieder so wie
in unserer Demokratie eigentlich gedacht
ist dass die Regierung mindestens eine
große Oppositionspartei gegenüber steht
die ein Alternativen Kanzler stellen
könnte hinzu kommt dass die Union mit
Friedrich Merz ein Oppositionsführer hat
dem selbst seine schärfsten Kritiker
nicht absprechen ein starker
parlamentsredner zu sein und lieferte
heute auch bei der Generaldebatte aber
auch sein Kontrahent Bundeskanzler
Scholz zog alle Register es ging hoch
her im Hohen Haus und so soll es an
solchen Tagen ja auch sein aus Berlin
Andreas kühners
ich hoffe Sie sind alle bereit da gibt
es seit Jahren das Bild vom starren vom
steifen vom stoischen Olaf Scholz da
gibt es seit heute Vormittag die noch
steifere noch stoischere Olaf Scholz
Wachsfigur und ausgerechnet da an diesem
Tag ist Olaf Scholz ganz anders in echt
und in Rage sie waren
[Applaus]
und sie haben Abwehrkämpfe geführt gegen
jede einzelne Windkraftanlage und jeder
Abwehrkampf der letzten Jahre schadet
unserem Land noch heute das waren Sie
Scholz schimpft auf Friedrich Merz
Scholz schimpft auf die Union in einer
wie selten erbitterten Debatte in einem
wie selten giftigen Klima März hatte
Scholz Versagen verzögern und das
vergeuden von Zeit vorgeworfen alles
müsse ans Netz auch die Kernkraft die
Lage spitzt sich in den nächsten Tagen
Wochen und Monaten möglicherweise
dramatisch zu und sie wissen es sie
haben die Gesprächspartner die ihnen das
gesagt haben und es dürfte alles andere
als eine Übertreibung sein ich sage
Ihnen der Bundeskanzler stoppen Sie
diesen Irrsinn aus ihrer Koalition
solange wir die Zeit dafür noch haben
herzlichen Dank
dann bekommt märz den neuen Scholz zu
hören die Union habe die Erneuerbaren
blockiert März Rede an den Problemen
vorbei und sei überhaupt schief
gewickelt acht Minuten lang sie haben
noch nicht mal gefordert dass wir dafür
sorgen sollen dass die Speicher voll
sind und da haben wir die Gesetze schon
gemacht sie könnten auch mal sagen dass
sie das eine beeindruckende Leistung
finden Herr märz die AFD wirft der
Bundesregierung vor ihren Amtseid zu
brechen sie habe jeden Grund sich zu
fürchten vor allem die Energiepolitik
müsse radikal verändert werden Schluss
mit der Ressourcen für Windkraft und
Photovoltaik sie sind nicht krisenfest
und ich versorgungssicher Windkraft
treten nur einen Bruchteil der
installierten Leistung zur Versorgung
bei Kernkraft nahezu 100 Prozent zu
Schränken hörbar und sichtbar der
Widerspruch aus allen anderen Parteien
vor allem die Grünen werfen der AFD vor
aus der Krise in Herbst und Winter
Profit schlagen zu wollen und meine
Damen und Herren egal woher Merz herr
Scholz oder Britta Hasselmann stehen das
werden die demokratischen Kräfte im Land
verhindern und darüber bin ich froh
während Kanzler Scholz versichert dass
es in der Ukraine Politik keinen
deutschen Sonderweg geben werde verlangt
die Linkspartei einen bilateralen
deutsch-russischen Einigungsversuch
sofort
sie müssen mit Russland in Verhandlungen
und über die Gaslieferung treten um die
Versorgung Sicherheit zu gewährleisten
das erwartet die Bevölkerung zu Recht
ich nehme sie beim Wort herr Scholz sie
haben gesagt die Sanktionen dürfen
Europa nicht härter treffen als Russland
bitte handeln sie entsprechend danke
schön aus der Koalition ein klares Nein
Deutschland werde aus der EU-weiten
Solidarität mit der Ukraine nicht
ausbrechen
Absicht russischer Politik dass Menschen
in der Ukraine sterben meine Damen und
Herren das ist das fürchterliche an
diesem Punkt das ist das fürchterliche
an diesem Krieg von Mohammed Ali der
Wachsfiguren Olaf geht am Abend ins
Museum starr steif und stoisch der echte
Olaf Scholz geht ins Kanzleramt er war
selten so lebendig wie heute
mit seinem Kurs in der Atompolitik steht
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck nicht nur
unter dem Feuer der Opposition und dem
Friendly Fire des Koalitionspartners FDP
auch aus der Wirtschaft hagelt es Kritik
und jetzt bekam er auch noch Post von
einem der Kraftwerksbetreiber Preußen
Elektra die das Kraftwerk Isar 2
betreibt äußert darin Zweifel das
harbex-plan Atommeiler nur als
Notreserve zu halten technisch machbar
ist was wiederum den Minister sichtlich
verärgert Klaus Brodbeck berichtet
leicht vorgestellt haben dürfte er sich
den Job nie doch für Robert Habeck kommt
es immer härter Tag eins nach dem
Stresstest und schon meldet der
Betreiber eines von zwei Atomkraftwerken
die möglicherweise weiterlaufen könnten
Bedenken an zwei der drei laufenden
Anlagen zum Jahreswechsel in die
Kaltreserve zu schicken um sie bei
Bedarf hochzufahren ist technisch nicht
machbar und daher ungeeignet um den
versorgungsbeitrag der Anlagen
abzusichern es steht jetzt schon fest
diese Vorschlag muss nachgebessert
werden der ist offenbar nicht solide
vorbereitet worden die Betreiber sagen
heute das geht so gar nicht da hat es
offenbar keine enge Abstimmung gegeben
und deshalb muss jetzt ein Vorschlag
vorgelegt werden der diesen thronten
energienotstand abwendet also entweder
hat Preußen Electra das
Wirtschaftsministerium vorab informiert
danach schaut es aus Robert Habeck hat
es schlichtweg ignoriert oder er hat mit
Preußen Elektro überhaupt nicht
gesprochen und sich nicht dafür
interessiert was die Betreiber der Kern
Handwerker zu dieser Entscheidung sagen
werden in beiden Fällen zeigt das nur
ein totales Chaos der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist vollkommen
überfordert der Minister ist sauer
Habeck fühlt sich und seine Pläne
missverstanden womöglich absichtlich
weil sie Preußen Elektra nicht gefallen
Preußen Elektra hat nicht verstanden was
der was die Einsatzreserve bedeutet sie
gehen offensichtlich davon aus dass wir
Atomkraftwerke wie Licht an und
ausmachen wollen das ist überhaupt nicht
das Szenario das habe ich auch mehrfach
erläutert das hätten sie eigentlich auch
wissen müssen wir beobachten die
Situation wie sich die Stromversorgung
Atomkraft in Frankreich Pegelstände rein
Kohleversorgung entwickelt und
entscheiden dann ob wir die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
radex Konflikt mit dem Betreiber
verstärkt gut hörbar das Knirschen in
der Koalition
es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten an
zusätzliche Strommengen zu kommen auch
das verstärkte Ausnutzen von schon
installierten erneuerbaren Energien
gehört auch dazu auch das muss genauer
unter die Lupe genommen werden da gibt
es noch eine Menge Möglichkeiten wir
denken nach wie vor mit dem Minister
zusammen auch in der Koalition dass die
Weiterführung der Kernkraftwerke
natürlich nicht die Lösung unserer
Probleme ist aber ich glaube als freie
Demokrat sagen zu dürfen es ist für uns
eine Lösung die Preise und den Strom
sicherer macht in Deutschland doch warum
erklärt die Betreiberfirma das
Atomkraftwerk und dass es geht zwar für
längeren Betrieb geeignet meldet aber
für hapex-plan technischen Bedarf
sollte der technische bedarf
bedeuten dass man sicherheitsabstriche
machen muss dann haben wir noch eine
interessante Debatte vor uns denn dafür
bin ich nicht zu haben es sind
Atomkraftwerke eine
hochrisikotechnologie und diese Aussagen
dass der sichere Betrieb gewährleistet
ist müssen natürlich auch überprüfbar
sein wir können ja nicht sagen das
glauben wir uns mal dafür stehe ich
nicht zur Verfügung klingt wie eine
Drohung ist auch eine man bleibe im
Gespräch versichern beide Seiten am
Abend fortsetzung folgt
nach einem heute journal Update gibt es
dazu noch ein Interview mit Nina Scheer
der Energieexpertin der SPD-Fraktion
der Verursacher des Krieges in seiner
Folgen steht derweil selbst offenkundig
unter ziemlichem Druck Putin reagierte
heute jedenfalls mit Drohungen auf die
Ankündigung der Europäischen Kommission
eine gemeinsame europäische gaspolitik
zu schmieden mit Preisobergrenzen zu
denen die Europäer russisches Gas kaufen
was sie noch Vorstellungen der
EU-Kommission möglichst gemeinsam tun
sollten und nicht jeder für sich selber
der russische Präsident drohte dann
werde er halt gar kein Gas mehr nach
Europa liefern vor einem halben Jahr
wäre diese Drohung vermutlich
wirkungsvoller zumindest schockierender
gewesen
angesichts der Pipeline Spiele die er in
den letzten Wochen gespielt hat ist ein
Teil dieser Wirkung inzwischen aber so
verpufft wie das Gas dass er lieber
verbrennen lässt als es zu liefern
über Putin und wie er die Welt sieht
kalt peitscht der Wind durch die
sibirische Weite in diesem Video
verbreitet von Kreml treuen Kanälen wird
wieder einmal vor einem kalten Winter in
Europa ohne russisches Gas gewarnt
während das Stärke demonstrieren soll
gesteht der Präsident heute ein das
sanktionsfieber des Westens wie er es
nennt hinterlässt Spuren
generell hat sich die wirtschaftliche
Lage stabilisiert allerdings sehen wir
Probleme in einigen Branchen und
Regionen bei einzelnen Unternehmen
insbesondere bei solchen die an
Lieferungen aus Europa gebunden waren
oder Ihre Produkte dorthin verkauft
haben
Russlands Inflation liegt offiziellen
Angaben zufolge bei 14%. das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist auf das Niveau
von vor vier Jahren gesunken und auch
technologisch werfen die westlichen
Sanktionen Russland zurück so baut
afrovers jetzt beispielsweise Autos ohne
Airbags und ABS der Automobilmarkt habe
quasi aufgehört zu existieren und nicht
nur der urteilt Wirtschaftsexperte
dimetrie Putter penko fundam die
Nachfrage der Verbraucher ist
fundamental zurückgegangen die Menschen
haben sehr schnell reagiert der
Immobilienmarkt ist eingebrochen die
Verkäufe sind um bis zu 97%
zurückgegangen etwa genauso stark wie
die Verkäufe von Neuwagen
durch die entspricht von tektonischen
Verschiebungen in der Weltordnung sucht
ersatzlieferanten für Mikrochips genauso
wie neue Absatzmärkte schmiedet eine
Partnerschaft mit Myanmars Militär
herunter Chinas Handel mit Russland
wächst um fast ein Drittel als Käufer
für Gas das bisher nach Europa ging
kommt die Volksrepublik wohl aber nicht
in Frage
das ist technisch unmöglich dafür müsste
man die pipeline-systeme
unterschiedlicher Förderstätten
verbinden die bisher für ein
unterschiedliches Publikum bestimmt
waren für unterschiedliche Märkte das
dauert und ist kostspielig
Gas gehen Osten umleiten unmöglich
Gaspreis bestimmen bald auch geht es
nach den Plänen der
eu-kommissionspräsidentin sie kündigt
einen preisdeckel für den russischen
Rohstoff an
wir alle wissen dass unsere Sanktionen
sich tief in die russische Wirtschaft
Graben mit starken negativen Effekten
aber Putin fängt das teilweise durch
Einnahmen aus fossilen Brennstoffen ab
also ist das Ziel hier die Einnahmen
Russlands zu beschränken die Putin
verwendet um seinen grausamen Krieg in
der Ukraine zu finanzieren
Putins Antwort gereizt er droht mit
einem Lieferstopp von Öl Gas und Kohle
sollte der preisdeckel beschlossen
werden
wie im russischen Märchen werden wir
sagen früher frier wolfsschwanz
ein Präsident der Märchen zitiert ein
pathetisches Propaganda-Video wohl auch
das zeigt dass die Sanktionen wirken
aber sie tun es langsam die EU der
Westen werden einen langen Atem brauchen
und dann schalten wir noch zu unserem
eu-korrespondenten Florian neuer nach
Brüssel Herr Florian wir haben es eben
gehört die eu-kommissionspräsidentin
will im Grunde ein
antiputin-gasbündnis schmieden wie ist
deine Einschätzung wird das gelingen die
Europäer da alle unter einen Hut zu
bekommen
das ist ohne Frage die umstrittenste
Idee der Kommission die sie heute
präsentiert hat in der Tat im Grunde
wäre das ja ein neues embargo eine neue
Sanktion gegen Russland die Europäer
würden nur noch einen bestimmten etwas
geringeren Betrag für russisches Gas
bezahlen aber ist sind nicht so naiv zu
glauben dass sie dann etwa für dieselbe
dieselbe Menge an Gas von Russland
bekommen werden ja und man gibt sich
aber trotzdem hier demonstrativ
entspannt Europa verweist auf zwei
Zahlen die durchaus beeindruckend sind
zu Anfang des Krieges bezog man 40
Prozent der russischen der gaseinfuhren
aus Russland jetzt sind es nach Angaben
der Kommission nur noch neun Prozent
also deutlich weniger aber eben immer
noch neun Prozent und vor allem
Osteuropa braucht dieses russische Gas
noch und so ist es heute die
tschechische Regierung die als erste
dieses diesen gaspreisdeckel ablehnt
pikant besonders deshalb weil Tschechien
gerade die rotierende
Ratspräsidentschaft der EU inne hat und
da eigentlich vermitteln müsste aber
diese Ablehnung zeigt bereits es wird
schwierig sich auf einen solchen
gaspreisdeckel zu einigen allerdings in
koalitionsvorschlägen heute und nicht
nur um russisches Gas sondern auch um
andere Energiefragen etwa das Europa
seinen Stromverbrauch drosseln soll
genau das war der erste der fünf
Kommissionsvorschläge es geht vor allem
darum in den sogenannten Spitzenzeiten
die Nachfrage nach Strom zu drosseln
dann nämlich wenn alle Strom brauchen
das ist in den Winterhalbjahr vor allem
am späten Nachmittag und frühen Abend
der Fall wenn alle Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher nach Hause kommen kochen und
dann vielleicht auch Fernseh schauen und
in diesen Spitzenzeiten da werden eben
die Gaskraftwerke zusätzlich gebraucht
die ja gerade besonders teuren Strom
produzieren und dann mit ihrem Strom den
Strompreis insgesamt in die Höhe treiben
und jetzt fragt man sich eben wie man
die Nachfrage an diesen Spitzenzeiten
etwas abfedern kann denkbar wäre etwa
dass man in der Industrie gewisse
automatisch ablaufende Prozesse in die
Nacht oder ans Wochenende verlegt oder
auch um ein ganz praktisches Beispiel
hier aus Belgien zu erwähnen hier sind
sogenannte Nachtstromtarife besonders
weit verbreitet das heißt der Strom ist
nachts billiger bei mir zu Hause etwa
läuft die Spülmaschine wie in vielen
belgischen Haushalten erst nach 22 Uhr
weil das dann eben weniger kostet und
das zeigt einfach ist das ein
Preissignal hier auch helfen könnte die
Nachfrage nach Strom zu den
Spitzenzeiten etwas zu drosseln
Dankeschön Florian nach Brüssel
und während die Europäer in Putins
energiekrieg bestehen müssen kämpfen die
Ukraine auf den Schlachtfeldern ihrer
Heimat
und nachdem was Militärexperten
beobachten gelingt es der ukrainischen
Seite offenbar die russischen Truppen an
verschiedenen Fronten unter Druck zu
setzen das ist natürlich immer schwierig
an Kriegsgeschehen aus der Distanz zu
bewerten und durch den sogenannten
kriegsnebel und Propaganda
hindurchzusehen aber es mehren sich doch
die Berichte teils auch bestätigt aus
russischen Quellen dass die Ukrainer
strategisch klug agieren und die Waffen
die sie haben einzusetzen wissen kann
man sehr viel Arian berichtet
sie ist sicher rücken sie seit Tagen vor
ukrainische Truppen bei ihrer
Gegenoffensive wie hier in der Region
herrson im Süden solche Bilder werden in
den sozialen Medien geteilt sie sollen
Geländegewinne zeigen wie hierbei wieso
copilia
[Musik]
wow die ukrainische Gegenoffensive läuft
seit Tagen im Süden und im Osten bei
hakiff heftig umkämpft soll hier die
Stadt balaglia zwischen Haki von easium
sein dort steht diese strategisch
wichtige Eisenbahnbrücke sollte sie
fallen wäre ein wichtiger Knotenpunkt
für den russischen Nachschub zerstört
also was die Ukrainer meines Erachtens
momentan worauf sie sich fokussieren ist
die Zerstörung von Nachschub wegen für
die russische Armee wenn die russische
Armee nicht mehr Munition bekommt nicht
mehr Material bekommt nicht mehr
Personal bekommt dann ist sie natürlich
erheblich geschwächt und das ist das
Hauptziel das gerade passiert die Armee
im Bewegung zu halten aber gleichzeitig
zu verhindern dass die Armee Nachschub
bekommen die gegen Offensive zeigt
offenbar Wirkung ein geplantes
Referendum der Russen in herson wo die
inzwischen auf november verschoben und
der russische Präsident so laut Pentagon
sogar Nordkorea um Munition gebeten
haben hier Archivbilder die geschwächt
ist die russische Armee
also nach dem was wir sehen wird die
russische Armee ziemlich hart getroffen
weil sie zwar Widerstand leistet der
aber an vielen Stellen durchbrochen wird
und das ist im Vergleich zum Don was
relativ ungewöhnlich liegt sicherlich
auch daran dass zu wenig Munition vor
Ort ist
wenn der Westen nicht mehr Waffen
generell liefern würde sondern
spezifische Waffen wie Schützenpanzer
und Kampfpanzer dann könnte die Ukraine
möglicherweise noch erfolgreicher sein
weil sie dann etwas könnte was sie jetzt
so nicht kann nämlich schnelle
Beweglichkeiten unterdessen haben
russische Kräfte heute erneut die Stadt
Harke beschossen wieder waren zivile
Ziele betroffen
unbeirrt vermeldet der Sprecher des
russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums seine
Erfolgsmeldungen und ignoriert die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive der
ukrainische Außenminister indes gibt
sich siegessicher
wissen wie wir die Russen besiegen
können denn wir haben keine Angst der
Krieg hat uns gelehrt den Feind nicht zu
fürchten wenn andere Staaten in der Welt
keine Angst vor Russland hätten würden
wir die Russen viel schneller in ihrer
Schranken weisen
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive kein
Wendepunkt im Krieg zwar so Experten
aber sie könnte eine Schwächung der
Russen im Süden bewirken mit einem hohen
Blutzoll
und jetzt geht es bei Hans Wolf weiter
im Bundestag ist mit einer
Schweigeminute das Verstorbenen
sowjetischen Präsidenten Gorbatschow
gedacht worden
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars sagte
Gorbatschow sei der Wegbereiter der
deutschen Wiedervereinigung gewesen er
habe die Welt zum Besseren verändert
Gorbatschow war in der vergangenen Woche
im Alter von 91 Jahren gestorben
die neue britische Premierministerin
Trust hat bei ihrer ersten Befragung im
Parlament ihre Pläne zur Bewältigung der
Energiekrise und der gestiegenen Preise
Umrissen Trust will die Öl- und
Gasförderung in der Nordsee ausweiten
und Stärke in Atomenergie investieren
für Privathaushalte und Unternehmen
kündigte sie schnelle Hilfe an und
morgen will sie ihre konkreten Pläne zur
Lösung der Energiekrise vorlegen
Brasilien hat heute 200 Jahre
Unabhängigkeit von der Kolonialmacht
Portugal gefeiert im ganzen Land haben
Feierlichkeiten stattgefunden an der
Copacabana in Rio de Janeiro gab es
große Militärparaden der
unterschiedlichen Waffengattungen als
Präsident verknüpfte bolsonaro seine
Teilnahme aber auch mit
Wahlkampfveranstaltungen vor den eigenen
Anhängern dies widerspricht den
Gepflogenheiten und wurde heftig
kritisiert in wenigen Wochen sind in
Brasilien Präsidentschaftswahlen
in Berlin blieben heute rund 2000
Arztpraxen geschlossen aus Protest gegen
geplante Änderungen an der sogenannten
neu-patientenregelung das
Gesundheitsministerium will
Krankenkassen entlasten und finanzielle
Anreize für Ärzte streichen neue
Patienten aufzunehmen und zusätzliche
Termine anzubieten der Spitzenverband
der gesetzlichen Kassen gab an das
boni-system habe keine Verbesserung
gebracht
in deutschland droht der Diesel
Abgasreiniger AdBlue knapp zu werden der
Bundesverband für Gütertransport und
Logistik warnt dass es schon in zwei
Wochen Nachschubprobleme geben könnte
einer der größten deutschen Hersteller
von AdBlue hatte die Produktion wegen
hoher Gaspreise gestoppt moderne LKW und
andere Diesel Nutzfahrzeuge sind auf
AdBlue angewiesen doch etwa 1,4
Millionen Pkw benötigen das
harnstoffgemisch
nicht alle Probleme mit denen die
deutsche Wirtschaft aktuell kämpft
lassen sich auf den russischen Krieg und
seine Folgen zurückführen schon vor
Kriegsausbruch gab es Kostentreiber und
Lieferprobleme Pandemie hat ihre
natürlich auch eine erheblichen Anteil
aber ein großes Problem unter dem viele
Firmen leiden ist schon viel früher
entstanden der Fachkräftemangel es fehlt
an erwerbsfähigen Menschen an
ausgebildeten und Auszubildenden und das
betrifft nicht mehr nur einzelne
Branchen Oliver Heuchert über die
Schattenseite eines Arbeitsmarktes der
heute selbst in konjunkturflauten anders
aussieht als in früheren Jahrzehnten
ein Arbeitsamt Anfang 1975 in der alten
Bundesrepublik die Zahl der Arbeitslosen
ist gerade auf mehr als eine Million
gestiegen der Beginn der
Massenarbeitslosigkeit jahrzehntelang
bestimmt sie die Kräfteverhältnisse auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt
jetzt aber gehen die sogenannten
Babyboomer in Rente damit verschwinden
in den kommenden 15 Jahren knapp 13
Millionen Menschen vom Arbeitsmarkt das
entspricht rund 30 Prozent aller
Erwerbstätigen qualifizierte
Arbeitnehmer werden knapp
deshalb treffen sich heute Minister
Wirtschaftsvertreter und Gewerkschafter
bis 2026 fehlen 240.000 Fachkräfte sagt
die Bundesregierung Wirtschaftsvertreter
gehen für heute schon von der doppelten
Anzahl aus der Begriff Fachkräftemangel
wird unterschiedlich gemessen groß aber
ist das Problem auf jeden Fall wenn es
uns nicht gelingt dieses Thema zu wuppen
in Deutschland dann wird
Fachkräftemangel nicht nur in der
jetzigen Situation sondern dauerhaft
zusehends zu einer Wachstums in
Deutschland
heruntergebrochen auf die einzelnen
Mangelberufe macht das Arbeitgeber nahe
Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft
folgende Reihenfolge auf am meisten
fehlen Sozialarbeiter Sozialpädagogen
Erzieher Altenpflege dann folgen
bauelektriker Krankenpfleger Sanitär und
Heizungstechniker Informatiker
Physiotherapeuten Kfz-Techniker
Berufskraftfahrer es fällt auf viele
Mangelberufe werden vom Staat oder
staatsnahe organisiert das gilt auch für
von denen es ebenfalls zu wenige gibt
außerdem sind die Mangelberufe fast alle
entweder Frauen dominierte oder
männerdominierte Berufe die größte
Quelle aber für Fachkräfte Sicherung im
Inland meine Damen und Herren das ist
eine höhere Frauen Erwerbsbeteiligung
was das Arbeitszeitvolumen betrifft auch
andere Branchen klagen das Gastgewerbe
etwa oder das Handwerk ganz generell
auf der Tagung heute sagt die
Bundesregierung sie wurde die aus- und
Fortbildung stärken und mehr auf die
Zuwanderung von Arbeitskräften setzen
möchte noch eins sagen
ausländische Fachkräfte werden wir
anwerben müssen und wollen also auch
wirklich sagen ja wir sind ein
Einwanderungsland für Fachkräfte und
dort geht es ganz besonders darum die
bürokratischen Hürden zu senken als das
letzte Mal ein offensiv auf Zuwanderung
gesetzt wird kommen Millionen
sogenannter Gastarbeiter das hat die
Gesellschaft mehr verändert als man
damals absieht
mit Wirtschaft geht es jetzt auch bei
die erstmal noch mal weiter Heinz ja die
Energiekrise führt zu Zusatzkosten
sowohl für die Verbraucher als auch für
den Staat der die Belastungen abfedern
will wie hoch diese Kosten ausfallen
dazu Frank Bethmann gibt es neue
Berechnungen ja das Deutsche Institut
für Wirtschaftsforschung Dew sagt da
könnte jährliche Mehrkosten von bis zu
1.500 Euro auf die Haushalte zukommen
und rechnet weiter vor pauschal
Ausgleichszahlungen an die Verbraucher
für alle diese Mehrkosten das würde die
Regierung mehr als 20 Milliarden Euro
Kosten begrenzt nur auf die Ärmsten
Haushalte käme man immer noch auf rund
vier Milliarden Euro und Anreize zum
garsparen hätte man damit auch noch
nicht Gesetz deswegen kommt das DW noch
mit einem anderen Vorschlag um die Ecke
einer Gaspreis Garantie aber nur für 80
Prozent des vorjahresverbrauchs aber
auch eine solche gaspreisgarantie wäre
nicht billig würde etwa 17,5 Milliarden
Euro kosten der Rest also der Verbrauch
der über 80% hinausgeht würde sehr viel
teurer abgerechnet werden besser aber
noch er würde eingespart denn eines ist
klar um akute Engpässe bei der
Gasversorgung zu vermeiden müssen auch
die privaten Haushalte ihren Verbrauch
drosseln um mindestens eben jene 20%
heißt es in der Studie Frank Bethmann
vielen Dank
der RBB Rundfunkrat hat die
Wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin Katrin
Fernau zur interimsintendantin gewählt
sie folgt auf Patricia Schlesinger
Fernau ist seit 2015
Verwaltungsdirektorin im WDR
am Abend hat Eintracht Frankfurt
erstmals in der Champions League
gespielt im heimischen Stadion hat
Frankfurt mit 0:3 gegen Sporting
Lissabon verloren und alle Tore alle
Begegnungen zusammengefasst auch die von
Bayern und Leverkusen heute Abend zu
sehen bei uns im ZDF um 23 Uhr im
Sportstudio Champions League
eine Tag nach der Niederlage bei Dynamo
Zagreb hat der FC Chelsea heute seinen
deutschen Team Manager Thomas Tuchel
entlassen auch in der englischen Liga
gelang der von Tuchel trainierten
Mannschaft nur ein durchwachsener Start
und auch RB Leipzig hat mit einer
Trainerentlassung auf die gestrige
Champions League Niederlage reagiert und
Dominik und tedesco mit seinen
Co-Trainern freigestellt die discoge
Band noch im Mai den DFB-Pokal mit
seiner Mannschaft
und noch die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 8 11 14 16 40 41 und die
Superzahl 3 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf Lotto Punkt zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht es dann weiter mit der
nächsten Folge von liberami und um 0.45
gibt es dann unser heute schon ein
Update mit na sanktemia bis morgen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend von Frankreich hier bringt
uns tief Peggy heute viel Regen und der
wälzt sich morgen weiter Richtung
Nordosten dort wird er gebremst und so
schüttet es auch morgen Nacht noch von
Schleswig-Holstein bis nach Ostsachsen
heute Nacht verlassen und Schauer und
Gewitter erstmal hier Richtung Nordosten
und von Südwesten kommt dieser neue
ergiebige Dauerregen an mit Gewittern
ist der durchsetzt der Welt sich bis
morgen früh weiter und erreicht dann das
Sauerland und auch Bayern heute Nacht
sinken die Temperaturen am Oberrhein bis
17 Grad bis auf 12 Grad hier im
Westerwald oder auch am Alpenrand und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
dann in der Lausitz bei 23 Grad am Rhein
bei 22 bis 24 Grad in einem großen
Streifen von der Küste bis nach
Ostbayern sind es dagegen nur kühle 16
bis 19 Grad das kommt uns dann schon
richtig herbstlich vor denn dieser
kräftige Regen zieht langsam weiter nach
Nordosten sie sehen wo es besonders
heftig schüttet es dro teilweise
Überschwemmungen denn bis morgen Abend
können örtlich 50 bis 80 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter fallen besonders Richtung
Sachsen-Anhalt südliches Brandenburg
Sachsen Thüringen und im Vogtland am
Oberrhein ist es dagegen sehr viel
freundlicher Freitag und Samstag wird es
weiter regnen und es gibt auch weitere
Gewitter aber die fallen dann nicht mehr
so heftig aus guten Abend